salut à tous bienvenue dans ce dernier
numéro de la saison du VSQ et vous ce
mois-ci notre dossier est consacré à la
recherche à
l'Université et ensuite retour sur les
actualité marquante du mois à travers
les
news pour finir portrait de Fabrice
chrétien qui nous parlera notamment de
ses récentes découvertes sur les
cellules sache et tout de suite le micro
trottoir bon numéro à
tous des recherches universitaires donc
je sais pas des études en langue en
histoire les sciences humaines les mat
la recherche je sais pas je sais
qu'iciici l'Université de Médecine donc
voilà je sais qu'il y a aussi des la fac
de Scien et de bio donc peut-être aussi
des des recherches en rapport avec ça un
labo d'histoire qui réunit aussi les
langues je sais qu'il y a des il y a des
labos en développement durable qui sont
sortis il y a pas longtemps en
économique et sociale je sais que il y a
pas mal de recherches qui ont été faites
entre autres avec Catherine nomnes mais
après sinon on n'est pas automatiquement
au courant des de ce qui se passe sur la
fac en tout cas dans les Labau de
recherche
quoi la recherche à l'Université c'est
l'une des grandes missions il y a une
mission de formation il y a une mission
de recherche c'est d'abord à
l'université que se fait la recherche en
France et à l'UVSQ qui est une jeune
université la recherche est
particulièrement développée comme l'
teste notamment les classements
internationaux dans lequel l'université
de Versailles Saint-Quentin s'est
insérée ces derniers temps je pense
évidemment au classement de shanghï ou
au classement de Taïwan
elle va du Développement durable de
l'Environnement jusqu'à la médecine en
passant par les sciences humaines et
sociales sciences du patrimoine par
exemple la robotique la cryptologie les
mathématiques nous avons 34 laboratoires
donc la recherche est effectivement
extrêmement diversifiée et nous en
sommes
fiers nous avons fait l'université une
grande université de recherche ce qui
est relativement rare chez les jeunes
université nous y tenons et nous allons
continuer à le développer et la prof
c'est la place qu'ut obtenir l'univers
unité dans les investissements d'avenir
une vingtaine de projets que nous
copilotons ou auquels nous participons
qui vont des laboratoires
d'excellence jusqu'au jusqu'à l'Idex sac
en passant là aussi par les équipements
d'avenir ou les partenariats publics
privés et puis il y a un secteur
extrêmement important également qui est
le secteur de la médecine avec les
cors l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin neline est une université
multidisciplinaire ceci est un atout
majeur parce queelle va pouvoir être
capable de répondre assez rapidement à
un certain nombre de projets qui
relèvent des enjeux relatifs à
l'évolution de notre société et des
besoins du monde socioéconomique qui
nous entourent alors ce sont des
domaines pludisciplinaires allant du du
Véhicule du Futur
décarbonés propre intelligent jusqu'au
patrimoine culturel la conservation des
œuvres ainsi de suite donc on a en fin
de compte ici pour chacun de ces
sujets-l un besoin de contribution de
différentes laborato de différents
laboratoires avec différentes
disciplines donc la cryptologie a aussi
la particularité d'être un domaine
pluridisciplinaire parce qu'elle va un
peu de des mathématiques des objets
mathématiques jusqu'à par exemple les
circuits électroniques et les
implémentation matérielle de de tout ce
qu'on fait en en crypto en passant par
l'informatique et aussi par la théorie
de l'information donc il y a vraiment
une complémentarité de plusieurs
domaines qui sont tous présents à
l'université donc nous avons un certain
nombre de collaborations avec des
industriels du domaine de la sécurité et
qui interviennent avec nous notamment
sur des projets de recherch
collaboratives des projets ANR des
projets du pôle de compétitivité des
projets européens et également
sous la forme de thèse CIFRE donc de
d'étudiants en thèse qui sont basés dans
une entreprise de ce type et ces
partenaires industriell interviennent
également dans des formations que dont
nous nous occupons notamment le master
secret pour la sécurité informatique et
la cryptographie à l'université
également l'université organisée cette
année encore le séminaire des doctorials
à destination des futurs docteurs ce
séminaire résidentiel est rythmé de
conférences de travail en groupe de
montage de projets innovants ou encore
de visite en entreprise il y a une place
pour eux à la fois pas simplement dans
le monde académique mais aussi dans le
monde industriel parce queun grosse
crainte de nos doctorants c'est
qu'est-ce que je vais faire après ma
thèse puisque souvent ils rentrent en se
disant je veux rentrer dans le monde
académique il nimaginent pas tellement
leur vie leur vie dans un secteur
industriel alors faut bien bien à savoir
que le ST industriel recrute énormément
de docteurs et de jeunes docteurs c'est
ce qu'on a vu d'ailleurs chez PSA chez
L'Oréal les 27 et 28 juin derniers les
experts internationaux de la conception
et de la simulation numérique haute
performance étaient réunis au forum
terateek notre laboratoire exaskel était
bien évidemment présent sur ce forum le
but c'est de se réunir donc tous les ans
pour disputer des dernières avancées du
calcul intensif quells sont les
dernières technologies
vre les futures technologies qui vont
tre développé commentment adapter les
applications pour cette
technologie à l'occasion du lancement
des inscriptions administratives
l'université organisé son tout premier
forum logement à travers différents
stand les futurs étudiants ont ainsi pu
trouver conseils et offre de
logement on a créé ce premier forum car
c'est une préoccupation importante pour
l'université de pouvoir aider ses
étudiants à se loger en fait dans un
contexte texte qui est assez difficile
et au niveau national et au niveau du
territoire mise en place à la rentrée
2010 la carte multiservice étudiante
permet de nombreuses fonctionnalités
attention cette carte est valable 3 ans
ne la jetez pas une fois l'inscription
administrative faite elle doit être
réactivée sur l'une des deux bornes
prévues à cet
effet
encadré notamment par les étudiants de
STAPS le centre de loisirs de
l'université accueille sur certaines
vacances scolaires les enfants des
personnels cette édition avait pour
nouveauté la participation du Comité
national olympique et sportif et du crit
dans un atelier science et sport les
enfants ont ainsi pu devenir l'espace
d'une journée de petits ingénieurs en
analysant leurs performances
sportives je me suis inscrit pour avoir
donc me familiariser avec le contact
avec les enfants parce que par la suite
je serais toujours en contact soit
d'enfants plus jeunes comme là ou
d'adolescents donc c'est important de
voir comment il agissent et leur leur
comportement au
quotidien zoom maintenant sur une
initiative étudiante très intéressante
dans le cadre d'un projet universitaire
des étudiants du Master Management
Qualité et conduite d'affaires ont
organisé une demi-journée de rencontre
entreprise étudiant pour favoriser leur
insertion
professionnelle en Master 2 on un projet
à suivre tout au long de l'année et donc
mon gros projet et moi on a décidé donc
de de suivre le projet réseau et vous
qui a donc pour objectif de développer
la notoriété du master mais aussi de
développer les relations
professionnelles les réseaux
professionnels en fait des
étudiants c'est tout pour les news de ce
mois-ci n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez
suivre toute l'actualité de l'université
sur notre facebook notre Twitter ou sur
www.uvsq.fr
je m'appelle Fabrice chrétien je suis
professeur d'histologie à l'université
Versailles SaintQuentin je suis
neuropathologiste à l'hôpital
raymondpcarré à Garche et enfin je
dirige une unité de recherche ici à
l'Institut Pasteur qui s'appelle
hisopathologie humaine et modèles
animaux mon parcours c'est un parcours à
la fois médicale et scientifique j'ai
réalisé mes études de médecine à
l'Université Paris Est à créteille où
j'ai été nommé assistant hpital
universitaire pu mettre de conférence en
histologie pour faire de la
neuropathologie et en parallèle de cette
formation médicale j'ai eu une formation
scientifique à Londres à Paris et puis
mon post-doctorat je l'ai fait à
l'Institut
Pasteur ce laboratoire est très
particulier parce qu'en fait c'est un
laboratoire où les chercheurs sont des
hisologistes ce sont des
hisstopathologistes et quand on a créé
ce laboratoire on a eu l'idée de faire
travailler ensemble des
hisstopathologistes qui étaient de
formation médicale et de formation
vétérinaire alors c'est quelque chose
d'assez innovant et ça nous permet
d'être à la pointe sur l'étude des
altérations dans les tissus à la fois
chez l'homme et dans les modèles animaux
de maladie humaine puisque de nombreux
modèles animaux de diff différentes
maladies humaines ont été développées en
particulier ici
restast dans l'unité il y a deux
thématiques de recherche principale une
qui travaille sur les altérations du
système nerveux central au cours des
infections et une autre qui travaille
sur le tissu musculaire et en
particulier sur les capacités de
réparation du muscle au cours du temps
ou après une lésion et donc dans ce
cadre on s'intéresse à une population de
cellules qui sont le des cellules
souches adultes présente dans le muscle
en condition normale et quand tout un
chacun fait un exercice un peu important
du sport ou bien après un traumatisme
ces cellules normalement servent à
réparer le
muscles on a été étonné d'observer que
ces cellules avaient une très grande
résistance à un stress environnemental
et elles sont tellement résistantes que
nos derniers travaux ont montré qu'elles
étaient capables de rester en vie quand
on les privait totalement d'oxygène et
également elles sont tellement
résistantes à un environnement dégradé
qu'elles peuvent rester en vie plusieurs
jours après la mort et jusqu'à 17 jours
après la mort chez
l'homme ces cellules qui reste en vie
très longtemps après la mort on est
capable de les extraire d'une biopsie
musculaire faite chez un sujet décédé de
les remettre en culture ces cellules
vont pousser former à la fois de
nouvelles fibres musculaires et puis ces
nouvelles fibres musculaires on peut les
regrffer ce qu'on a fait chez l'animal
et reformer du muscle parfaitement
fonctionnant avant tout les perspectives
de ce travail sont des perspectives
scientifiques c'est très important de de
le souligner on n'est pas du tout à
l'aube d'une nouvelle source pour la
thérapie il y a encore de nombreuses
validations à faire mais ce qui est très
important c'est d'avoir identifié un
mécanisme d'adaptation de cellules à un
environnement qui est très défavorable
et ce qui est très intéressant c'est que
ces cellules quand on les prive
d'oxygène quand on on les met dans un
environnement hostile et bien elles
s'endorment sont dans un état qu'on a
qualifié comme état de dor
et gardent tout leur potentialité sans
s'activer en conséquence là ça pourrait
correspondre à un moyen méthodologie
pour conserver ses cellules au cours du
temps voilà c'était le dernier numéro de
la saison mais on se retrouve dè octobre
bonnes
vacance